прем'єр-міністр України Денис Мигаль під
час візиту до Німеччини заявив що
Україна зможе взимку експортувати струм
до ЄС але за умови що Запорізька АЕС
буде у безпеці чому Україна продає
електрику під час війни чи врятує це
Європу від холодів і чи вистачить
електроенергії самим українцям утрати
української енергетики за даними
Міністерства енергетики через війну
Україна втратила половину потужностей
теплових електростанцій а також третину
Сонячної генерації і 90% вітрової
Запорізька Луганська і Вуглегірська
теплові електростанції Каховська ГЕС
перебувають під російською окупацією так
само і Запорізька АЕС хоча
електроенергія з неї досі надходить на
українську територію десятки
електростанцій на півночі і сході
України пошкоджені або зруйновані
водночас припинили роботу і великі
підприємства споживачі струму наприклад
комбінати у Маріуполі до того ж мільйони
українців виїхали за кордон як наслідок
споживання електроенергії з лютого
скоротилося на третину нині Україна
більше виробляє струму ніж споживає
Україна завжди мала надлишок генеруючих
потужностей але в умовах газового
шантажу Росії це відкриває нові
можливості для експорту як Україна
продає струм Україна з 1996 року
продавала електроенергію європейським
сусідам Монополію на експорт Мав так
званий Бурштинський Острів це електрична
мережа бурштинської електростанції на
заході України яка була під’єднана до
європейської електромережі Війна змінила
українську енергетику За чотири години
до початку вторгнення Росії Україна
від'єдналася від енергосистем РФ та
Білорусі це відключення було плановим і
мало тривати три дні але затягнулося
судячи з усього назавжди українська
енергосистема екстреними темпами
синхронізувалася з європейською тепер
електроенергія може вільно потрапляти з
України в Європу і навпаки нині Україна
продає струм в Польщу Молдову туди
експортувати почали з березня і травня
відповідно згодом струм пішов у Румунію
Словаччину Угорщину яку електроенергію
експортує Україна більшість
електроенергії в Україні традиційно
виробляли атомні електростанції
теплові
6 решта на альтернативні джерела енергії
під час війни сонячна і Вітрова
енергетика втратили майже всі потужності
але загальний Розподіл це значно не
змінило атомні електростанції є
залишаються основним джерелом енергії на
експорти де мікс з різних видів
електроенергії теплової атомної водної
але незабаром ситуація зміниться
українська система інтегрувалася з
європейською має запровадити сертифікати
відповідності електроенергії з такими
документами можна буде продавати
згенерований без шкоди середовищу так
званий зелений струм завищує ціною
скільки Україна продає струму
повноцінний експорт електроенергії в ЄС
відновився 30 червня спершу обсяги були
мізерними 100 м гавач щогодини нині в
пікові години він сягає трьохсот мегават
до кінця року уряд прагне дійти до
показника щонайменше 800 МВт поки що
обсяги експорту малі тому що Україна має
встановити отримати спеціальні пристрої
з татком які балансуватимуть коливання
напруги міністр енергетики України
Герман Галущенко ставить за мету довести
пропускну спроможність для експорту до 6
гігават на це піде щонайменше рік
скільки Україна зароблятиме на експорті
електроенергії в Укренерго запевняють
збутися залежності від російського газу
а Україні накопичити кошти на підготовку
до опалювального сезону в уряді очікують
що прибутки від експорту щороку можуть
бути такими ж як і за транзит газу з РФ
А це понад мільярд доларів щороку з
кінця червня Україна заробила три
мільярди гривень на експорті
електроенергії експерти кажуть що нині
Києва надзвичайно вигідно продавати
струм у ЄС на цьому графіку видно
європейські ціни у 6-7 разів вище за
українські це явище пояснюють дефіцитом
газу ремонтом атомних енергоблоків у
Франції і відмовою від атомної
енергетики у ФРН водночас фахівці
застерігають коли ціни на електроенергію
в Європі впадуть потреби в українському
струмі може зменшитися до того ж проти
дешевої електрики з України можуть
виступити власні європейські виробники
Чи вистачить українцям електроенергії
частка експорту електроенергії незначна
з березня по серпень цьогоріч Україна
експортувала один і три мільярди
кіловат-годин електроенергії це менше
двох відсотків від усього виробітку за
минулий рік Україна продала три з
половиною мільярда кіловат годин Це дещо
більше 2% від згенерованого струму тоді
щоправда Україна Ще не була підключена
до європейської енергетичної системи
тому експерти певні що Україні вистачить
електроенергії і для внутрішнього
Споживання і на експорт але за умови що
стабільно працюватимуть усі українські
АЕС А це в умовах війни складно
прогнозувати якщо власник потужностей
бракуватиме Україна зможе імпортувати
електроенергію з Європи Утім ціни на неї
будуть врази вищими